minister i do want to ask you about
indian trade but i'm going to have to
ask you about events at home because
things are very live and very difficult
for you
back in london
why did you perform a huge u-turn today
and decide to drop an attempt to delay a
vote about investigating you by the
privileges standards committee
the most important thing is that we
allow the investigation by the by the
met to continue and i think all other uh
and to conclude and then for sue grey to
uh to make her her final uh report and
um
what i decided uh is that you know if
the opposition really want to focus on
this and they and your own mps uh that's
fine uh
i'm afraid it wasn't a
conservative nation as far as i can
remember no but you were clearly worried
about what conservative mps i think i
think it's very it's very important that
nobody should say that we're trying to
avoid scrutiny and i don't want to avoid
scrutiny and
um so why don't you try and block the
vote because i what i don't want to do
is to have
um
endless discussion about this when we
don't know the conclusion of
uh the labour management doesn't
doesn't start the inquiry until the
investigation is concluded so that is
completely ideological just we just need
it
get the thing concluded
if people want further conversation
about that i don't want to uh in any way
to to dissuade them i happen to think
uh that
you know i've made my point i i
apologize for
very much for
uh the fpn that i received um
we've taken steps to change things in uh
in number 10. um but we need to focus
frankly on the things that matter to the
people of this country uh directly now
okay how to how to make sure that we
continue to come on jobs growth
what i felt was people were saying look
this looks as though we're trying to uh
to stop stuff
coming out i didn't want that i didn't
want people to be able to say that i
don't want this thing endlessly to uh to
go on but if you know i'm i have
absolutely nothing frankly uh to hide
here nothing sometimes no let's let's
but if if that is what the um the
opposition want to to talk about that's
fine okay what i want to talk about is
the uh
point of this trip uh which is
steve baker who is a key ally of yours
helped you get elected a key brexiteer
said in the comments today the pm it
should now be long gone he should know
the gig is up that must hurt well you
know
steve faker i i understand uh people's
feelings i i don't think that that's the
right thing to do i think we've got to
wait for the conclusion of the uh of the
report and and perhaps i could say a bit
more then that's what that's what i said
in the meantime and what i what i would
like to do
is get on uh with taking the country
forward making sure that we deal with
the immediate problems that we face and
i i'm particularly proud of some of the
things that uh
you said that you have nothing to hide
but you are also under investigation for
up to all five events you were involved
in up to five more events
i know you can't but you might have more
fines you do accept that beth you're
gonna have to wait okay conclusion of
the report when i ask you yes in the
meantime you promised to get on to that
i think people were here you did
this isn't the kind of competition to
see you can do more i'm just what are
you doing why don't you get on to the
subject of the trip i would just like to
ask you this
you said on the plane last night when i
said are there any circumstances in
which you might feel that your position
is unsustainable or you might have to
resign
you said nothing springs tomorrow i said
to you and i'm sure you could you could
you could uh elaborate some for the
benefit of your viewers but i think what
i want to do you could you know extend
price on what i want to do is get on
with
uh the the job uh which i was elected to
do you said
and that's what we're focused on but you
also said that you wanted to get on with
things that matter to voters do you
think
that the issues around rule breaking at
number 10 doesn't matter to vote no i
don't know and i apologize for uh for
the things i apologize deeply for the
things we've got wrong i came to the
house on on tuesday made a two-hour
statement i did another uh half an hour
or more i think on
on wednesday uh
i believe there's been a big debate on
it today uh but we've got to get on uh
with the priorities of the of the people
that's what we're doing
and you think it's a storm in a
westminster tea couple those are your
words
so you don't think it's that you do
think
i think of course i think it's i think
it's serious and it's important but i
also think that we have massive issues
that uh people expect us to address and
i think that people want us to get on uh
with the job of taking the country
forward uh making sure that we attract
further investment and this country is
attracting record investment right now
it's a fantastic thing to see and you're
just as a result of this uh trip to
india uh you've got
just today you've got investment worth
yeah uh a billion billion pounds uh
producing 11 000 clear though tomorrow
tomorrow
what we're signing yes because you've
gone about step if you let me finish
this um you just to be clear you you
said about the fine you had and the
apology
that you didn't realize that you had
broken rules that it was a genuine
mistake to be clear
at all times even the bring your own
bottle event
in number 10 garden on may the 20th
at all times did you always think in
every single event you were not breaking
the rules so you never thought you broke
the rules
you're asking me to comment well you
said you had nothing to hide and i'm
going to comment at the end of that
investigation i've been very very clear
about that what i was saying is i don't
i don't uh
shrink at all from having uh more
parliamentary scrutiny if that's what
the opposition want what i want your
mp's
indeed but what i want to do is focus on
the things that matter i think to uh the
the future of the country uh and that is
making sure that we uh help people with
you accept that because of this energy
you accept your mp's are unhappy then
so that's your those are your words uh i
want to get on and deal with uh
priorities one more one more question
this night and then i want to ask you
about the trade deal you you've had a
torrid time sorry um
just this
and then
you'll have notoriety time do you really
believe that the party that the country
will allow you to to lead the
conservative party into the next general
election right here right now you're
absolutely determined to do that of
course i am and what were what i'm
determined to do is to uh make sure that
we continue with our agenda which is to
uh unite and level up don't forget this
is the the government that gets done
some very very difficult things uh we
deliver the fastest vaccine rollout in
europe we came out of covet faster
than anybody else we got brexit done and
when people said it was impossible and
we've led the world in uh standing up to
aggression i think even you would
concede beth i stand up to aggression uh
in uh
finally and and we will get on we will
get on with that work and and since you
now come to the point of the trip thank
you very much uh let me just remind you
that uh that uh what we hope to do
is a uh a free trade deal with uh with
india uh by the autumn i think it has
great potential you've already got uh
things like uh uk medicines uh uk uk
food
uh
agreements have been done in advance uh
apples
uh you'd be thrilled to know uh are
going to be able to come to this uh
market in a way they haven't been able
to come uh before uh and and and much
more besides there is a huge amount that
unites the uk and india ukraine
look at well give me one example
the the very vaccines i just mentioned
are a classic example of collaboration
between the uk
and india 1.5 billion people
around the world vaccinated thanks to
kova shield which was basically a
an anglo england indian collaboration
prime minister thank you so much thank
you